hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in one of the
passages which we looked at in another
core concept video Epicurus says that it
is impossible to live pleasantly without
living prudently well and justly and
what does it mean to live prudently or
to live according to practical wisdom
well one way of understanding that is in
terms of what we call practical
rationality or practical reasoning that
is reasoning about what is good and what
is bad what we ought to do how our
desires ought to be formed what sort of
choices we ought to make that's all part
of practical reasoning now being a
hedonist Epicurious thinks that the
central goal is to live a happy life and
a happy life means the most pleasant
life the life that actually has the
greatest degree of pleasure and in
return the the least amount of pain so
he also has and we've discussed this in
several other videos there's a priority
according to certain kinds of pleasures
that's going to be very important mental
pleasures over merely bodily pleasures
so books over beer you could say it's
what he called static pleasures over
moving or kinetic pleasures that's a
little bit more of a
technical distinction and you're going
to want to look at the video on that to
put it in a thumbnail so moving
pleasures are those which require us to
do something to enjoy something like
like drinking a beer right or you know
scratching an itch
static plungers are those which we enjoy
when pains when troubles when demands
and needs have been removed and we just
enjoy this wonderful state where nothing
really is going on but it's really
enjoyable so there's a priority of those
and also an avoidance of mental pain
because mental pains like fears for
example the fear of death are according
to Icarus much worse than the physical
pains though that we could feel you know
there's that that Shakespeare quote that
people like to bring up that you know a
hero dies just once but a coward dies a
thousand deaths is a thousand or a
hundred I don't really remember in any
case that's a lot right even if it was
just - it would be more and the idea is
that the coward is somebody who's beset
by fear and that fear makes them suffer
more than the hero who actually suffers
one death now if we want to be good
practical reason errs one of the things
we need to do is examine what is to be
chosen and what is to be avoided because
that's a practical reasoning culminates
in choice and avoidance this is how it's
been classically understood there's a
few passages that I want to bring up
that deal with this one is from the
principal doctrines he says if you do
not on every Sun every separate occasion
refer each of your actions to the end
prescribed by nature but instead of this
in the act of choice or avoidance swerve
aside to some other end your acts will
not be consistent with your theories so
if you're an epicurean and you want to
be doing good practical reasoning you
need to keep that end of being happy of
being happy for your you know as much of
your existence as possible not just the
immediate gratification available to you
in the present if you want to be
consistent your choices at avoidances
need to be consistent with your theories
about the nature of choices and
avoidances so what is he able to say
about this well I like it good here on
the board you want to count the costs of
pleasures in terms of other pleasures
and pains so he's got this great passage
in the letter to men osseous where he's
discussing moral theory and he says
every pleasure is a good and account of
its own nature every pleasure is good by
itself right so that makes sense that
doesn't mean we should pursue everybody
says that doesn't mean every pleasure is
worthy of being chosen just as every
pain is an evil and yeah every pain must
not be avoided so why would we not
pursue every pleasure and not avoid
every single pain he says we have to
estimate all these things by the
measurement and view of what is suitable
and unsuitable for at times we may feel
the good that is the pleasure as an evil
and at times on the contrary you may
feel the evil is it good and we think
contentment
that's this again a great good not in
order that we may never have that a
little bit in order that if we have not
much we make use of a little being
persuaded that those men enjoy luxury
most completely who are the most able to
do without it so there's some reasoning
going on here right he also says just a
little bit before that you know we
affirm the pleasure is the beginning and
end of living happily we recognize this
is the first good and with reference to
it we begin every choice and avoidance
to this we come as if we judged every
good by passion as the standard and
since this is the first good and an
eighth yes we do not choose every
pleasure but in time pass over many
pleasures when any difficulty is likely
to ensue from them and we think many
pains better than pleasures when a
greater pleasure follows for them if we
endure the pain for for a time so think
about exercise for example I hate
exercising I used to really enjoy
exercising but it's depending on all
these twenty years since I really enjoy
exercising which is why I'm a little bit
overweight and I'm not in particularly
good shape you know
if I have to you know do a lot of heavy
lifting or or walk a long distance I
feel a bit winded and you know I'm not
up to the things it would be good for me
to get in shape and it's one of the
reasons I don't do it is because it's
kind of painful to do alright but that
would be a really good pain to endure
because it would lead to greater
pleasures or at least a lack of pain you
know a classic example actually one
unfortunately that I suffer from is
arthritis if you are arthritic then you
need to keep moving even though it hurts
a bit to keep moving
because if you allow yourself to say I'm
just gonna take it easy and stay still
the arthritis will actually get worse
but if you can keep yourself moving you
can find that the the physical pain
isn't so bad in its part because you
actually need to keep everything you
know moving along that's some good
practical reasoning right there he goes
along and says a couple other things as
well he says question each of your
desires was a really smart thing to do
isn't it what will happen to me if that
which this desire seeks is achieved and
what if it's not so when you have a very
strong desire to say oh I want to get
that you know does this would be my life
would be so much better if I bought that
thing ask yourself ask that desire what
would really be the case what would
actually result from this or probably
result from that's not just what you
you're telling me desire but what's more
likely to result from this what can my
experience teach me and how bad is my
life gonna be if I don't buy that thing
if I don't pursue that pleasure if I
don't drink that bottle of wine if I
don't listen to you know go go listen to
that concert it may not be bad at all as
a matter of fact you may be freeing
yourself up for other things again
practical reasoning you have to actually
count the costs against each other you
can't just go and buy instinct or
feeling if you're an epicurean this is
actually a very deliberate kind of
living that that's going on
he also says no one chooses the things
seeing that it's evil but being lured by
it when it appears good in comparison to
a greater evil he's caught all right so
we have to be careful to distinguish
what's really good and what's really
evil again for Epicurus it's going to be
in terms of pains and pleasures he says
no pleasures in itself evil but the
things which produce certain pleasures
entail annoyances many times greater
than the pleasures themselves great
example of this cheating on a partner
right you're in a committed relationship
and it would be easy to cheat with
somebody else you know let's say you're
gonna here's a classic case or any
movies are made of this theory at a
conference you know a convention right
insurance convention and and you're in a
big hotel and you're down at the bar and
there's a beautiful or handsome stranger
across the bar from you and they're
coming on to you know you you know
you're let's say you're even in the Las
Vegas right so now you're thinking all a
lot you know what stays and what happens
in Vegas stays in Vegas whatever
nonsense you want to tell yourself right
you're posed within it with an issue it
would be fun to go off and have sex with
that person or you know even just you
know make out and flirt or something
like that
that's cheating too you know on the
other hand what sort of pains might
result in that that's the sort of thing
that people don't ask themselves when
they're jumping into that situation or
they minimize those pains or they they
they minimize the probabilities of those
pains happening but if you're really
thinking through probably not a good
idea from a practical reasoning
perspective you know morality at least
for Epicureans is in large part a matter
of prudence doing what's probably going
to to turn out best for you thinking
about how pleasures and pains lead to
each other
he also says where is this one there are
some pains that we choose precisely
because we're ready to leave the
pleasures so they balance each other up
here's a couple other things that are
to take into account he says the
magnitude of pleasure reaches its limit
in the removal of all pain so when we're
trying to come up with a standard for
you know achieving the central goal we
do have to keep that priority of static
pleasures in mind the removal of pains
the removal of all pains takes us to a
kind of limits
Epicurus thinks that it's actually more
pleasurable state to just be at rest and
have a few simple plunges simple food
simple you know garments a nice garden
to have conversations in with friends
and stuff like that that is more
pleasurable than the sybaritic life of
you know pursue every pleasure possible
so I'm curious would be more for it
sitting in the garden than say going to
Vegas right that's an important thing to
keep in mind this notion of limit the
other thing that he says and this leads
us to the importance of habit and
discipline it says most men are
insensible when they rest and may add
when they act so most of us according to
Epicurus aren't quite ready at this
point to to take you know the criterion
of pleasure as our guide we need some
practice in learning how to appreciate
rest how to appreciate the lack of
trouble of pain of anxiety the freedom
that comes with that most men are he
says insensible they don't realize how
good they've got it at that time right a
man when they act mad because they don't
follow practical reasoning and they just
go pursue some pleasures or avoid pains
without thinking about the consequences
if we act in a deliberate way which
would be part of the practical reasoning
practical reasoning tells us that we
ought to go about our pleasures and
pains in a deliberate way and we want to
structure our life and our relationships
in such a way this will not be the case
for us the other thing that he does tell
us that I am I don't have the the quote
right in front of me so I'm gonna
paraphrase it is that we have to
our bad habits and dispositions as if
they were evil people who want to do us
harm so if I find for example in my own
life that I'm subject to fits of anger
and that that causes me pain because
anger itself is a painful emotion and
that it causes the people around me pain
and alienates them from me to a certain
extent causes rancor damages the
relationships then I ought to look at my
own anger my own erratic ability my own
tendency to fly off the handle or to
hold grudges
something like a person inside of me who
is constantly screwing up my life who
wants bad for me if if I'm self
indulgent when it comes to food and
drink you know if I can't keep myself
each night from eating a bag of chips as
I watch you know a show on TV and I feel
bad if I don't have that bag of chips
even though my body doesn't mean it my
body probably needs the opposite of that
I should look at that habit I should
look at that disposition as if it's an
unfriendly malicious person who's trying
to do me harm that also falls under
discipline and that also falls under a
practical reasoning or the activity
that's involved with prudence